new police footage tonight showing the
intense car chase turned shooting on
i-15 last week
that claimed the life of a nevada
highway patrol trooper
this as the community continues to mourn
his loss
orc omana joining us now live from nhp
headquarters with the new details
tonight orco
denise trooper micah may was just trying
to stop a carjacking suspect last week
when that suspect hit him on the i-15
law enforcement across the valley are
mourning his loss
and tonight we're getting our first look
at police footage showing
everything unfold making another u-turn
back
westbound cheyenne new footage shows the
chaotic car chase that eventually led to
nevada highway patrol trooper micah
mae's death
metro says the suspect douglas claiborne
stole someone's car last tuesday
threatening the owner with this foot
long knife aerial footage captures
claiborne driving erratically on i-15
and the surrounding streets evading
parole and probation officers
and nhp troopers stop stick tire
deflation devices were deployed
numerous times yet claiborne was able to
move or
maneuver around them police say
claiborne intentionally hit trooper may
when he put stop six on i-15
trooper may then flew through the
windshield troopers eventually rammed
the car
stopping it new body camera footage then
shows a handful of public safety
officers and troopers opened fire
and officers then observed claiborne
grabbing trooper may's gun
this prompted the officers to fire their
weapons at claiborne
claiborne died at the scene trooper may
was flown to umc in a metro helicopter
but he unfortunately passed away
two days later the community has rallied
behind trooper may
including during a procession over the
weekend that show of support
is not going unnoticed on behalf of
trooper
micah may's family and the dps family
we would like to thank the kind people
of our las vegas community
there is a candlelight vigil scheduled
for tomorrow night to honor trooper may
it'll be held at police memorial park
and everyone is welcome to attend
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now